hey y'all it's andrew couch here and in
this toy tuesday video we're not gonna
be looking at this week's data set
instead we're gonna build upon our tidy
models um
videos and do some um more machine
learning stuff
so i was reached i was going through the
tidy models github
and saw that there was a stacks package
and this is a package for stacking your
tidy models or doing some ensembling
so you'll comment you'll usually see um
stacking
or model ensembling in like competitions
like kaggle
where you're essentially combining uh
separate machine learning models
predictions and creating another model
into it so for example this is like a
nice little diagram of your models
you're using these models
outcomes to predict uh the outcome
and these models can basically be
represented as coefficients with like a
lasso
regression model so it's cool that
there's
a package for this to make it a little
bit more tidier
and neater so i thought it'd be kind of
cool to do
a short little video of creating an
ensemble model
using tidy models and the stacks package
i will also know that this is the
unstable version so you can't do
install.packages
you have to do a remote install
additionally
some of the functions may not be working
or may change
so uh this this is just kind of a basic
uh
intro to see what the stacks package is
about and what we're trying to
accomplish
so i'm gonna load up a tidy mod uh a our
markdown sheet i'll call it
tidy models ensemble
okay um and for this since we're using
this
new package i thought it'd be pretty
smart to use
the aims housing data set so i'm gonna
do
tidy models typers uh
id models
aims housing
and then the stacks package
also paste paste this in um
just so you can use it you can install
it
if you have not installed the package
already so then we'll do the
make aims
we can do a basic uh
kind of glance at it so just do a
summary
let's see how we have all this stuff
since this data set is basically already
cleaned for us we don't have to really
worry about it
and i figured we just make our seeds and
our trains and test sets first so i'll
say
train and test sets so
set that seed it's the 13th
we do a tidy split um this is just the
generic um
modeling modeling procedure so we're
going to create a training test
split using our df prop is 80 20 so
we'll do
80. we'll oops
80 and then we'll get make our tidy
train so
training tidy split
uh tidy test which will be our testing
tidy
split and then we'll create our k folds
data
which will be v fold cv and we're going
to create
we'll we're going to use our training
data set as our validation k-folds uh
data set
so tidy train okay so that's basic data
partitioning
nothing crazy and now we're going gonna
go over kind of the main
approaches for ensemble modeling so one
of the main things with ensemble
modeling is
you want your models to be different
um it's generally not real it doesn't
make a lot of sense to use like
the basically the same xg boost models
or ensembling you want to have some
diversity into it so i figured we'd
first kind of start with a basic
uh preprocessing function and i figured
that
a common um
model that's pretty simple is a pca
regression model
so just gonna be a linear regression
model using pca as a preprocessor
so we'll create our recipe we're gonna
be predicting sales price because it's
the ames housing data set
we're going to give it our train data
to our tidy tidy train data
okay and then we're going to probably do
some
um basic pre-processing since if we look
at our tidy
our training data set we have 81 columns
with a bunch of factors a bunch of
continuous variables
so i figure we should do at least some
data we should remove some of these
columns
and do some dimensionality reduction
the first i'm going to do step near zero
variance
and i'll say all predictors so any
predictors that basically have no
variants in it will be removed then i'll
do a step
uh correlation and say all
numeric minus all outcomes which will be
removing any highly correlated variables
okay we're also going to do a step
linear
linear combination so any linear
combinations
um which will remove some of our
variables hopefully
okay so this is basically our
dimensionality reduction for continuous
variables
i also want to remove some of these
classes
so some of these things like if we look
at
um subclass we might have a oops
study um
so we have a bunch of factors for this
and i fear we would want to kind of
reduce this especially we're doing one
hot encoding
etc so what i'll do is step
uh other and say all nominal so in this
case if there's a minority class it'll
just convert it to others so
if it only shows up three out of the 500
times it'll be converted to a
other variable okay then what we're
going to do is step
normalize all uh
numeric minus all outcomes
because we're going to be doing some pca
or principal components
analysis um we're going to then dummy
the variable so all
nominal or categorical and lastly we're
going to do is step
pca and we'll say all
predictors and for our components we'll
just use
five components okay so if we do our pc
rec
uh prep it we can see
we do all of our pre-processing features
we have our dummy variables
our linear combinations i guess it
didn't find anything it removed
um some sparse variables and some um and
it didn't remove any correlated
variables
which is fine um so if we do our prep
and
our choose we can see we can see how it
basically condenses it to
five principal components to predict
sale price that's gonna be
our linear and we're gonna throw this
into a linear regression model and use
that to predict
um sale price where we're gonna actually
uh blend it in
with some more models okay
on the next thing that i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a spline
model so spline rec
uh recipe sale price
data equals tidy terrain
okay uh we're gonna do the same thing
where we're just gonna do step near
um no zero variance near zero variance
since we know that step correlation step
linear combination
i won't do anything i could just remove
this but i figured we'll just uh
leave it in just to make it a little bit
cleaner
so we'll do that okay
um we're gonna remove all of the
nominal value so only we're only going
to be dealing with continuous or
numerical data
and then we'll do step bs
basis uh splines and we'll say all
predictors
and lastly we'll do a step yo johnson on
the
all predictors okay
oops sale price
okay so we have this spline rack
so kind of like a spline or uh mars
model style
if we do a prep oh there's a fly here
we see that he's doing all this stuff
uh if we juice it
we can see that we have a decent amount
of variables uh which might be
bad for a linear regression but we're
going to be ensembling so it won't be
used for our last model
okay finally we're gonna do a basic
recipe
uh we're gonna be adding on to
on these things uh we're gonna do a step
uh uh normalize
so all numeric and then
step dummy all
nominal except numeric and then we'll
say
minus all outcomes
okay so this is our recipe these are
our three recipes for some models that
we're going to be using
so with our tidy wreck we'll do prep
juice
so essentially this this model will be
for or this tidy recipe or like baseline
recipe will be used for our more
um uh stronger black box models such as
our like a random four
an xg boost our spline and pca models
will be used with these simpler
like linear regression models okay so we
basically have
three types of preprocessing that we're
gonna use and we're gonna do it we're
gonna apply it to a few models
okay first let's make our pca regression
model
so pca regression model linear reg
uh step set oops set
sorry set mode regression which i think
it defaults to
set engine to
engine to lm so we're going to do a
basic linear model
not a gl net or lasso or
uh or a ridge regression we're just
going to do a basic linear regression
and then we'll also do another one which
will be our spline
regression i would say spline
model okay then we'll
create a random forest model a rand
forest min n will be tuned
and trees will be tuned
that mode to regression
and then set engine to i'll just do
random
forest okay finally for our fourth model
we'll do
an xg boost model so a boosted tree
and i'll just tune the learn rate and
the trees and the tree
depth
and then we're going to set the engine
to xg boost
okay so we have our models
um one thing that we have to do is set
our
model controls so with our tune
with our stacks package what we're what
we're going to need to do is actually
save the predictions
because essentially it's going to be
using each model's predictions
and comparing it to the actual value and
then modeling these predictions as
coefficients
so we're going to do a model control
which will be a
controlled grid we're going to save our
predictions which will be true and we're
also going to have to save our workflows
which will be true
because it wants to do these
preprocessings
to our model so when we're using our
final stacked model
it should be able to do the pre unique
pre-processing for our pca spline
random force and xgbs models inside of
our model
okay i'm also going to do a model
metrics function so
we're just going to do the the classic
regression metric so rmse
mae and r squared
okay so we have our
define models define
um tuning
uh control
and i'll say define
pre-processing okay
and then finally what we're going to do
is create our grid so
define grids
so we'll do a grid regular parameters
of our random forest model
our levels will be three so with this
uh i don't like how we are only using
one tree so i'm going to change that so
i'll do filter
see trees is less than
uh trees is greater than one
so that way we're doing one thousand two
thousand one thousand two thousand
wait um so call us the was it
grand forest
grid and then we'll do the same thing so
grid regular
uh parameters actually boost
model levels equals three
and i'll say filter c trees
filter uh
trees is greater than one so we have
more than uh
oh so we have about a thousand trees for
a minimum amount of trees
of course the xgboost grid
okay so now we have our grids and
finally what we're gonna have to do is
define our workflows
uh so we're just see we're basically
combining all this stuff so our models
are pre-processing
and then we're going to start tuning it
and then giving it uh passing along into
a stacked ensemble model
and using that to evaluate on our test
set
so we're going to create our workflows
so workflow um
add model pca regression
model and then add recipe
pca rep we're going to create our spline
workflow
add model spline model
add a recipe spline correct
uh random forest workflow
our models
give it our baseline recipe which will
be our tight recipe and then our final
workflow which will be our work our
actually boost workflow
so you might notice something um our
linear models should not have any
parameters
so that'll be very easy to fit um for
our random forest and our actual boost
models we're gonna have to fit it
okay so finally what we're gonna do is
fit
models so for our pca workflows and our
spline workflows we're just going to do
a
fit resamples so we'll say uh
pca res it resamples
we give it our pca workflow our
resamples which will be our k
folds data our metrics will be which
will be our model
metrics and then we'll give it our
control
which will be our model control
great and now i'm gonna oops
copy and paste these in so it'll be our
spline res here
spline workflow our
random forest res which are with give it
our random forest
workflow give it our actually boost res
and then give it our
gps workflow
okay so i'm going to run this but i act
i actually already have the results from
this sample
so uh we'll um
load it in and actually it's not fit
resamples for these guys it'll be a
tuned grid
and a tune grid but these guys don't
have any samples so we're just gonna
don't have any um parameters to tune so
it's going to be
fitting a model um and then evaluating
on the
evaluation or k-folds data in this case
it's going to do the same thing
as our pc and splines we'll also show it
trying every parameter
um grouping in our parameter grids that
we gave it
actually i'll be uh grid is equal to x g
boost red
um grid is equal to random forest
uh random forest
grid and i have it
yeah okay rand forest ran forest grid so
it'll be uh
rainforest grid okay so we can run this
but we have a uh
file already that i tuned last night we
have our load our
r data if you look at our pc res
we actually have our results right here
great so now what we're actually gonna
do is working on the actual stack
and with this stack it's pretty easy so
we just have to initiate stacks
and then we're going to start adding our
candidates so essentially since we saved
our predictions
we can look at our was it pca res
we can do a collect predictions
and we have our predictions right it's
pretty good
um we also have our id or row ids too
so it's pretty easy to say okay um pca
predicted this the actual thing is that
combine all of our model predictions
together
and build another model to break sales
price given our model predictions
so we'll do that aim stack uh we'll say
stacks
we'll add our candidates so let's do our
pca res
add candidates our spline
res add candidates
our random forest res
add candidates our xgboost res
so this is actually going to run into an
error um specifically with our xgboost
results and i'm not sure why it's
doing that it's saying list columns um
and this is this is one of the problems
with a of
a a new pack that's still being
developed is sometimes will run into
bugs
so if i remove actually boost it'll fit
perfectly
so we have our aim stack and saying a
data stack with three model definitions
and eight candidate members
because our random force model has uh
six sets of parameters that
it was tuning on so with our aim stack
what we're gonna have to start doing is
blend our predictions
and this is basically um figuring out
which what type of uh
combination of models we should be using
to
uh make our predictions for our final
ensemble
uh model so it's saying is oh we should
heavily weight
our random forest model and we should
lower our rate
our weight for our spline rez
okay so once we have that we can do aim
stack blend predictions
and also fit members
okay
so now we're fitting the um essentially
we're fitting
each of our models predictions to the
sales price
so our model saw our actual data such as
like housing
um uh size of rooms number of bathrooms
and our aim stack is just seeing our
model predictions for sale price
so it's not seeing as much features it's
just seeing kind of these summarized
uh features what the model sees and what
it believes the
house value is
okay
it's still running um we'll just wait
here
and one thing that i will say is since
we have this problem where we can't add
our xgb's model
um i think it'd be kind of interesting
to just kind of do
the um to do the ensembling by ourselves
using your models um without the sax
package um the sax package makes it way
easier and a little bit much uh with
less code to actually create ensemble
models
but it's still pretty easy to make a
ensemble model
uh with just base tidy burst functions
okay
so we finished training we can see our
aim stack
pretty good it says out of eight
possible blending coefficients the amps
the ensemble used two using a lasso
penalty
of uh this this score so it only used
two of our actual models it only used
our random forest model and our spline
model it ignored our pca model
which is kind of interesting uh so we
have our aim now we have our final aim
stack model
let's actually do it now um in base tidy
versus
way or the tidy burst way without the
stacks package if you wanted to do it
by yourself and didn't want to work with
a package that has a decent amount of
bugs
okay so first what we're gonna have to
do is give in our
random forest
our random forest res and are actually
boost res
we're going to just collect the best
metrics so we'll say show best
and we'll say rmse okay
and i'm just going to say slice 1 select
trees and min
n and that will be our final model
okay actually boost res we'll say select
or show best
rmse uh slice one
and we'll say select trees to
learn rate okay so this will be
our random forest
uh was it final
pram actually boost
and we'll say final ram okay
so now that we have our final params
we'll actually start creating our
predictions so
we'll say actually boost res
but now what we have i'm going to say um
finalize
um parameters and say
collect model predictions
to stack so with our xgb spreads we can
actually do is collect
the predictions and we have a problem
here
so for example we've tuned multiple
models so we're gonna have to say is
uh we'll just do a inner join
with our xgboost final param that's
joining by
tree tree depth on ordnance right so
it's just keeping
our final models okay we'll select the
i d the row
dot pred and sell price
so this will be xgboost
stack and then let's do it for our
random forest
uh res so i'll do a collect
predictions inner join
random forest final param make sure it's
joining correctly which is treason
n and we'll do select id dot row dot
pred
and sale price
great so we have that i'm going to also
change something so i'll just say
actually boost is equal sale price
so it will say like in this case it'll
be our actual prediction is our actually
boost prediction
and we'll call this random forest is
equal to oops
sale price and it's not sell price it'll
be dot
pred dot pred and then we'll change that
to sale
price okay so we're gonna change our
prediction names to the actual model
names
um okay
so random forest and we'll call us
stack and now let's look at our pca res
so p sierras
uh collect predictions
select id dot pred
uh dot select dot row
uh we'll say pca equals dot pred and
sell price okay
and let's call this the uh eca
stack
finally we'll do our spline res so
collect
predictions
and then we'll do the same thing so
select id dot row
uh spline is equal to dot pred
and sale price and i know i could just
rename it but i figured we just kind of
make it a little bit cleaner
to look at of what i'm actually doing so
spline
back okay so we have our stack
and then we'll create our final stack df
actually i don't think we'll
we don't need sales price for all of
them so i'm just going to remove that
okay so now let's actually join these
together so actually boost
stack left join random forest
stack left join um
eca back
left join spline stack
and it's joining by our id and row so
that way we have the same predictions
for the same sale price
and this will be our stack ef
okay so create ensemble
data create stack data
and i'll say uh
okay so i could have to clean this so
i'll say create
stacks model
cool so now that we have our stack df
what we can actually do is just
fit a generic uh lasso regression
so linear reg
so penalty we'll just say penalty equals
point five
mixture is equal to uh one
well i guess we yeah yeah we'll just to
make sure equals one so it's not
actually
actually uh no it is loss of regression
okay so set bow to a regression
to engine to oops
into glm net
and fit it to sale price data
is equal to stack df
great so now we have our stack model
let's actually look at the coefficients
so we're going to do a tidy
[Music]
stack df oops and then i need to also
plug out minus id minus that row
okay so we can look at our coefficients
it did shrink our pca model
uh but also it still kept the xgboost
model and we have our splines
we get so we can actually change this to
zero if we don't want to completely
remove a model
and that's one one thing where you can
definitely just mix with you know
using your lasso your ridges or your
elastic nets for your models
um some common other models you use for
stacking is decision trees
so you have decision trees linear models
etc um
generally you don't want to go too
complex until i can actually abuse a
random forest
but you can it just leads you more prone
to overfitting
which is very easy to do when you're
dealing with always modeling
uh stuff with a lot of data leakage
okay so now that we have our final model
um let's actually just do our final uh
workflow
so actually boost workflow so always say
finalize
sub models so in this case we already
have our model
we just need to combine our our
parameters to our
actually boost and random force
workflows and then we're going to do our
last fits
okay so actually boost workflow
actually boost workflow uh finalize
workflow and it's what actually boosts
final pram
last fit and we give it our tidy split
okay and i'll do the random forest
workflow while it's training
random forest uh workflow
finalize workflow give it our random
forest final pram class
fit tidy split
we'll do it for our pca workflow cool
which will be pca workflow
class fit tidy split
and then we'll give it to our spline
portfolio
spline wf last fit
tidy split
okay so it's doing that wait a little
bit
and these models will be very fast while
it's doing that i'll actually say
predict i'll say uh extract
uh predictions from sub
sub models so i can actually can create
a list so tibble
so models is equal to list actually
boost workflow
random forest workflow and pca workflow
and spline workflow i'll say
uh names or model names is equal to c
g boost random forest pca
and spline
and then i can do a mutate
and i'll say predictions is equal to
map model and say collect
predictions
and i'll say uh final
stack final df
wow that's taking a little bit longer
than i expected it to be to take
but it should it should do it pretty
fast let's see here
yep okay just did it right when i check
so we do that these are just you know
pca and spline so it'll be fine
okay so we have our final predictions
from our sub models
okay uh we can select
our model names and our pred
on spread
uh what i can do is
uh pivot wider names from
model names values from
dot pred okay
select minus id minus dot row
okay so now we have these things
what i can do now is actually um use our
model to predict on it
so i'll just say predict or was it stack
model
it's called uh was it what i call again
stack model
right so that's our stack model
um i'm actually gonna
say stack final df and then i'll say
okay predict uh stack
model stack final df
and i'll say bind calls stack
df okay so now we have our prediction
our sales price actually boosts
spine uh we can also do a
pivot uh
pivot longer i shall do a all rename
to stack is equal to dot pred so that's
our stack prediction
we have our xgb's prediction our random
force prediction pca prediction and
spline prediction
uh converts this to a tidy format minus
sale
price and then what i can do is a group
by
name and then i can do
a forecast metric oops it's a model
metrics truth is equal to
sale price estimate is equal to
value oops
estimate is equal to value okay and then
we'll do a ungroup
uh pivot wider just so we can read it
pivot the metrics values from
equal dot s submit
cool so what do we see here
um i'll do a range by rmse
so our stack has a lower rmse
a lower mae and a slightly higher r
squared
and you can see how it beats all of our
models and all of its metrics
and that's good because when you're
doing predictive modeling challenges
that extra one percent of predictive
power can make you win
that competition so in in so in reality
stack
when you stack models you're not going
to get like a 50
increase in performance but you will get
some marginal performance and that's
what many people do in capital
competitions
um generally in cow competitions people
are not just using an xg boost model
they're using multiple models
and stacking them together to make a
final output
because you don't have to worry about uh
long prediction times say like if you're
in a production setting you just have to
worry about exporting out
a highly accurate csv finally let's
actually look at our
aimstack model
so if we do our uh was it ames
uh with ames stack
we predict our aims stack with our test
data
i think our tidy test
right uh bind our columns for the tidy
test
select still price
and then we do a uh was it a model
metric so truth is equal to sale
price estimate is equal to dot pred
s estimate is equal to dot pred
pivot wider names from equals dot
metric values from equals dot estimate
dot estimate okay i read that
and what we can see here when combining
with our other other uh stacked model
is we actually have a higher higher rmse
than our xg
boost model so it does not perform as
well as our
our our custom stack model our custom xg
boost model
but it still has some pretty decent
performance
okay and you can see how um doing the
aim stack using the stacks package
was much easier with less data munching
so for all this work right here um
could it not to be condensed into into a
one like two into a two liner right
because these are these are a piped in
function
so hopefully the aims i'm hoping the
stacks package improves where we can
start adding more
models or i can just figure out what i
was doing wrong
but you can see how the uh the stacks
package
is a nice framework and it really
follows the tidy framework of tidy
modeling
and you can see how stacks definitely
just improves your performance across
the board usually
it might it may not increase it by a lot
but
um after 20 minutes they increase your
percentage by two percent um predictive
power
is worth it for a lot of predictive
competitions um i know i went
uh over a package that may be changing
but i thought was pretty interesting in
my research
uh last for the weekend so hopefully you
guys can do
uh some more modeling and kind of
improve your models using stacking
or win some cattle competitions
but in the meantime i'll see you guys
next week and tidy on